I'm Sara varelli I'm the development
director at the MIT game lab I came I
came to the game lab from the game
industry where I've worked as a producer
and a game designer and a QA person I've
kind of done an awful lot of I've done
an awful lot of jobs and seats I've
worked on I worked on thief thief one
into flight ultimate I worked it I
started at Looking Glass and that's
actually where most of my work was done
I then worked at irrational for a while
and that's when I moved to the game lab
I came on to be a specialist in
production production management and QA
testing and those remained the areas
that I teach in in the course
specifically I I also helped I also I
mean we all do a little bit of
everything but I lead the lectures on
agile and organizing your team and
keeping it running and I also do a lot
of the testing lectures and focus
testing lectures
what am i playing now right now I am not
playing but I'm hoping to play soon is
the newest release of Minecraft which
has bunnies in it which both I and my
daughters are very excited about so I'm
I'm hoping that tonight I will be able
to actually go home and arrange for a
play session of Minecraft with them I'm
also playing a fair bit of sentinels of
the multiverse and most recently we've
been tackling the Pathfinders card game
which is almost a way to play an RPG in
a short amount of time except that it
takes almost as long as a full session
of playing a sit-down RPG so far we'll
see if we can get it faster
right now I'm not actually working on
any games I'm was working on a climate
change game I'm moving away from that
and trying to think about more and what
is a more interesting problem to work on
sort of in the area of not just teaching
game design but using game design using
people learning game design to learn
other subjects as well so you can tie
two things together and that's sort of
I'm playing around with how do you teach
that how would you how do you structure
a course that would do something like
that
I'm actually really excited to having a
specific a specific sort of design
question that we're asking the kit the
students to look more deeply into into
making decisions for the player and
making meaningful decisions because
that's a part of games that the simpler
your game is the harder it is to invite
your player to make meaningful decisions
and to set up situations where they're
they are making those but that tends to
be the part of games that I at least
find the most interesting the places
where I'm making choices and I can see
how my choices have completely sunk my
ship or enabled me to win the game I
like knowing that I I have control of my
destiny and so getting the students to
get to explore that aspect of games
better and more deeper I think is really
nice
I'm currently also working on creating a
game with the step lab introduction to
game design on MIT at X I think it's 11
point 1 to 6 X is the number I believe I
spent so much time making the game that
I have not been making the course that I
have not been looking into all the
administrivia attacked to do it but
working on that trying to condense a
game course into six weeks has been
really hard and it made me really stop
and think about what is the actual
important things of game design
I would like games to go well they've
already gone some of the places I want
them to go games that are looking at
more social integrating more social
experiences games that aren't just in
board games where you're not just me
playing against everyone else but you're
playing as a team and you're playing
cooperatively and video games are also
doing that I mean they've been doing
that for years and thing in the massive
multiplayer games and things like that
but seeing video games go more for how
do we work together how do we make this
a more social experience and what I'd
really love to see is games getting the
point where players get to affect the
games back especially in the RPG space
where if I'm a big enough player and I
can now defeat everything in the game
trivially can I go in and change the
game to make it more interesting for
other players can I take some of that
and then that actually goes all the way
back that was already being done back in
muds right this is something this is not
actually a new concept it's just that
production quality has gotten so high
but you can't do that anymore well with
all the tools coming online can we sort
of can we bring that really neat players
giving back into the game and creating
experiences for other players maybe we
can start bringing it back into the
high-end games too